welcome back to pleas sensor live from
New York City I'm joined Now by my P the
founder of the communitybased
Palestinian lead organization within our
lifetime Nadin kwani former conservative
MP Louise mench and the broadcaster
Emily Austin all right uh let's try and
keep things civilized shall we um Nadine
I guess for you two things um you were
born in Jordan you just told me off fair
you're an American Cien but very much a
Palestinian in your heart obviously and
your blood what did you make first of
all before I get to what um what masab
yev was saying what did you make of
Queen Ran's comments as the queen of
Jordan about all this you know I believe
that all Arab leaders um can take a
stronger stance in support of
Palestinian Liberation particularly
considering that you know the entire the
the citizens of Jordan most jordanians
support Palestine if anything actually
most um people who live in Jordan are
Palestinian descendants that have been
ethnically cleansed from their land and
ended up as refugees in Jordan just like
my family did um and so I believe that
you know uh Jordan and and all these
Arab countries should stand
unequivocally with the people of
Palestine even stronger now and M ABF
there I mean it's an extraordinary
interview with a guy whose father was a
founder of of Hamas he's absolutely
clear that he believes you got to get
rid of Hamas and then there can be peace
and they can be what people want there
do you agree with him I believe if you
want to stop Palestinian resistance
you're going to have to kill every
single Palestinian because regardless of
whether what if you want to stop Hamas
terrorism I believe any form of
resistance Palestinians take is going to
be called terrorism but terrorism isn't
resistance if you actually commit an act
of Terror how can Palestinians defend
themselves in a way that isn't
considered terrorism well I'll give you
the difference which was argued actually
Gary kaspero the chess uh Legend today
articulated what he saw was the
difference on October the 7th hundreds
of terrorists invade a country is Israel
and they brutally rape assault murder uh
set on fire innocent civilians that is
by any yard stick an act of appalling
terrorism Israel responds with what they
say are targeted air strikes at places
they believe Hamas are hiding in Gaza
that's disputable I get that but that's
what they say they are qualitatively
different the death toll may not be
different but the intention of what is
going on is different and that's exactly
what happened in deia in 1948 where
people were raped where villages were
pillaged to un fire bombed at tantura
where Palestinians had to dig their own
Graves before they were shot into it
England started just to finish this
point England orchestrated this genocide
so I'm actually happy that you know both
of you are here um we resisted you know
but uh you know but you're you have a
lot of reach there um so we resisted
when there was the British occupation
and and we will continue to resist any
occupation that exists in Palestine all
right let me bring it inem I just want
to ask you a question so last we left it
you did refuse to uh condemn Hamas
murdering Israelis on October 7th and it
seems as if nothing has changed but I
couldn't help but to think do you Al do
you condemn 911 that's such a ridiculous
this is an interogation of I'm a New
York City it's it's a simple question
course no it's of course stop deflecting
question ridiculous of course between
Israel's 911 I'm not here to is she the
interviewer or are you she's raising I
think I think the point she's making and
yes I'm wrong is if you condemn that why
won't you cond that was Israel's 911 I'm
not here to answer her questions because
palan are we did this last week I will
now ask what Emily just ask it's
actually a valid question isra 911 if
you're happy to publicly condemn 911 why
are you not happy to condemn Israel's
911 it was a lot worse
statistically 911 is palestine's 24/7
that's
completely bring bring in Louise here I
found it really shocking I have to say
that your organization within our
lifetime said that it was an act of
resistance on October the 7th I mean
that is the most unislim thing I've ever
heard in my life tying the hands of
little children behind them covering
them in petral and then burning them
alive please tell me what is resistance
about such inhumane torture of kids
since you want to bring up Islam in
Islam we believe that the blood said of
any innocent person is equal to killing
all of humanity um and this is something
that you know we believe unfortunately
Palestinians are put in a situation
where they're in an open air prison what
we were celebrating that day is them
breaking out of that open air prison I
don't understand how the world is one of
the reasons is one of the reasons why
you're not so Keen to condemn what Hamas
did on October the 7th because you're
fearful of publicly doing that are all
Palestinians fearful of speaking out
against Hamas actually because there's a
very reason very good reason to be
fearful no there's no reason to be
fearful my life is not if anything you
know living in New York City my whole
life there are many Zionist institutions
including the universities that I
attended um and campaigns against me for
being pro Palestinian including putting
my face um on trucks to drive around
Midtown and Time Square for two weeks um
just this summer calling me a Jihadi so
that's what I'm it's not because you're
Pro Palestine it's because you're Pro
murder there's a big difference we are
all Pro Palestinian Liberation from a
terrorist group called Hamas apparently
everyone here but you what about from
the occupation are you Pro Palestinian
Liberation from the occupation the you
want to talk asking me questions
changing the topic the one time I asked
you
question I'll allow that you you have
asked her question she can ask you go on
I just asked do you support Palestinian
Liberation from The Siege and blockade
and the occupation that's factually
incorrect how can I talk to somebody
B United Nations partition plan divided
the land you waged the war you does have
to do with a
1 Emily what I would say about that one
country if one country in this case
Israel is able to turn on and off the
tap of water and power and food for the
people of Gaza that is not a healthy
situation you can call it what you like
you can call it occupation you can call
it repression you can call it control
but that surely when they talk about
freedom for Palestine what they mean is
we're not rying on Israel giving us
water food and energy so we can actually
exist correct and I'm happy you brought
up that point because they want their
own territory they want their own
government governmental body so when we
pulled out in 2005 2006 why couldn't
they establish that for themselves why
are we giving electricity and water to
begin with and my question is where is
the hundreds of millions of dollars of
Aid being sent directly to Palestine
directly to Gaza where is that money
going but it was a uh rhetorical
question it's a question toward rocket
$600 a rocket over $500 million well I
would raise a different point actually I
ra bring Louise more NBC News more than
80% of gaza's population live in poverty
poverty according to the UN we can all
agree that but Hamas has an Investment
Portfolio of real estate and other
assets worth half a billion dollars and
an annual military budget of $350
million a lot of electricity one of the
most disgusting things about this entire
period of time has been watching Hamas
leaders sitting in Doha in Kata in their
fstar hotels telling poor Palestinian
civilians do not evacuate do not listen
to the IDF do not get out of these areas
that are being bombed and preventing
them from leaving that is a war are you
comfortable with that no that's totally
untrue and and I'm glad that you brought
that up because naftali also spoke at it
earlier when he talked about how they
gave the order to evacuate the North and
we all know that they gave this
evacuation order um toza on October 13
and what did they do when people when
they told them there's going to be safe
passage on this road for them to
evacuate they bombed that passage there
no zero
evence not
verified now you're a conspiracist as
well okay and there's a lot of things um
that zionists are doing that are that
are killing Palestinians like Biden
saying yesterday that the number of
Palestinians that have been killed may
not be true when we when the Palestinian
Ministry of Health had to come out and
release a PDF 231 pages of the names and
the ID numbers of every single I think
the point he was making is I I wouldn't
believe the word of a terrorist on
anything right you don't see them as
terrorists I do I want to talk about
Palestinian lives because you can't be
selective 40% of Hamas Rockets backfire
and kill innocent civilians the outrage
it is verified and I will I will provide
the source right after the show quote me
on it it is verified and secondly
Palestinian outrage about civilians is
very selective when the alleged Israeli
Army allegedly killed 500 Hospital
victims um when they found out it was
the Islamic Jihad where was the
outrage Islamic Jihad they did it's
confirmed it is confir so you want to be
a fact you want to talk about one
Hospital how many hospitals how many
Healthcare facilities have been bombed
by Israel I don't need to focus I don't
need to focus on one particular
Hospital you went shelters we know this
for a fact are you bothered that they
lied are you bothered that the Hamas uh
I'm bothered that your government I'm
bothered that your government that you
used to repres and that the US
government yes of course what kind of
question is that I'm devastated that
7,000 Palestinians are murdered I'm
beyond s% I'm devastated and I'm
devastated that I pay taxes to the
government that is doing that you can
leave you can go back to Gaza can I go
to Gaza can I go no I can't I was
actually denied entry to Palestine for
over for almost 10 years I was denied
entry okay when I was 20 years old
because my let me just say something
time out um I do find these
conversations complet completely
gripping I have to say because passions
are running very high on both sides I
think you both articulate your opinions
extremely well I think they resonate
with a lot of people the last interview
that you you both conducted with me has
had millions of views this one we do
again we should keep talking right one
of the things through this is to keep
talking in Northern Ireland where we had
appalling terrorism for a long time
eventually we got to a peace settlement
because people just kept talking and
Leadership came through that actually
wanted peace yeah and journalism is very
important when it comes to this and
getting the word out there and talking
and unfortunately we know that the
family of the AL
jaaz buau Chief was killed okay you know
after after they told qar to turn down
the volume on Al ironically I have to I
have to leave you there because I'm
going to talk to a very good friend of
Evan gersovitz who's of course the Wall
Street Journal journalist who's been
held captive in Russia so it's not just
in this situation happy birthday to Evan
it's his birthday today and I'll be
talking to to his good friend the break
thank you all of you for coming in thank
you so
much